I
just listening to one kick king at
dinner jørgen now what makes him a Roman
but for me is get some beer Allah
communicates with conscience and it's
clearly a man of vision the these two
immediate put together make something
very very exciting us with the same kind
of healing sparing penalties as
President Obama when he speaks you feel
like you know him there's no barriers
and this is something that's very
exciting and as someone who's studying
again theology is someone interested in
faith and study the Middle East and with
a surname white pony I've always been
told there's no
peace in the Middle East well I think
they're with communicating their
conscience leader like this would be the
person Obama who supports this peace
process I think they really is home and
my organization global tournaments are
stop Lynas communications and functions
and I think that we work on here CSS
importance in the release of a role
model but it starts their plan is to
reservations and every single home in
the Middle East and beyond